[Music]
annie
is with us and annie is in albuquerque
hi annie how are you
hi dave hi john thank you for taking my
call sure how can we help
um okay so i have a sister who's in her
30s
and she had a kid when she was 21 years
old
and she's been a bartender for about the
last seven years before coded
and for the last several years my sister
has been taking money from our father
and grandmother
and they fund several parts of her life
um
for example she's never had a car
payment both my dad and my grandmother
have both purchased cars for her and
so she's never really had to make any
effort to improve her
lifestyle and like she'll say
that she's going to do things and then
she doesn't follow through
and so my question is more about i'm
starting to feel resentment
toward my sister because i feel like
she's taking advantage of our family
they don't really have the financial
means to be helping with these
situations
and they've been bailing her out of her
uh situation
financially for years and i just want to
know how i should proceed with a
relationship with her
have you ever talked to her about it i
feel this way have you ever talked to
her
no i have talked to my dad about it
my grandma is way old to talk to her
hold on a second how come you ever
talked to your sister about it
um well we had a falling out we are just
now starting to talk again we had a
falling out because she had made some
pretty bad relationship
decisions with a significant other and i
didn't support it
yeah it was a very abusive situation and
i didn't know what to do
so i just said i don't i don't know what
to do here yeah so this
is one of those family conversations
that sounds a lot more complex
in reality than it really is um
the reality is you don't have a lot of
power in this situation and so
what you can control is the boundaries
you want to set up
and the conversations you want to have
other than that
your mom and dad your dad and grandma
get to decide how they spend their
grown-up money
and your grown-up sister gets to decide
if she wants to continue to
leech off other people or if she wants
to get her life together
the choices you have are to have a hard
conversation with your dad and your
grandma and say i think you're being
taken advantage of by our sister
and that's about as far as that
conversation can go and then you can
have a hard conversation with your
sister and say
i don't like how you're treating grandma
and um dad
other than that you get to choose where
you want to carry around a bunch of
resentment
and frustration and
because that pain is in your heart
that's not on anybody else that you're
choosing it's almost
willfully choosing to wake up every day
frustrated right
what do you think dave yeah well you're
exactly right one of the hardest things
in our lives is
when there are adults that we love that
are being stupid
and you can't keep them from being
stupid there's no law it's stupid
stupid is not illegal and it's in almost
every family by the way
like every family and so some put the
fun in dysfunction but i mean it's uh
but you know it's just it's hard it's
hard to watch people you love
so the only way you possibly uh can do
any good with your sister is just say
uh i think you could have a better life
than you have and it breaks my heart
that your life is
not good and it's not good because of
some of the choices you're making and
man i would love to walk with you and
spiritually disciple you whatever
on making some different choices and um
cutting the ties where you're
being supported as a grown woman by mom
and by dad and grandma
and if i can help you with that i love
you and i think you can do i think you
can do better
and i think you're going to have a
better life and talk make it about her
doing better
rather than how bad she is and uh
go ahead i was saying and do you do you
want to have a relationship with your
sister
or do you want her to stop yes yes sir
so badly
so you don't have one now or you have a
you have a broken one now
right yes sir we're reconnecting now
so slowly what i'm going to recommend a
great way to heal a relationship
is not to come out with somebody letting
them know they need to make a bunch of
life changes
and they need to fix some stuff that you
don't like
sometimes the best way to start and
repatch and reheal a relationship is to
say
i love you how are you how you been how
can i help you i've missed you how can i
help you
and to start there and true
life change comes through relationship
it comes
through connection not through somebody
barking orders at you
and so i'm going to recommend if you
want to and the reason i ask you that
question is some people just want their
sister to quit taking their future
inheritance they just want their
dad to start getting taken advantage of
that's different than
man i miss my sister and i love her and
i want to reconnect with her
those are two different processes and
two different approaches but man
i say call her direct and say i love you
let's get together and we're going to
start from there
yeah as far as your dad goes if you do
want to have another conversation
uh it could sound like this dad you're
an enabler
you're bringing harm to so and so
by helping them um because all of her
character muscles have atrophied and so
because here's the thing your dad and
your grandma i know about enablers one
thing i know about all of them is
they're the nicest people
and they love deeply they just they just
love they just want to be helpful
and if he can if he can become convinced
that he's actually doing
harm which he is rather than helping
then he will suddenly grow a backbone
and introduce a new word no
because he is doing harm to your sister
and as a dad if he ever gets that
he'll stop it but as enablers all feel
like
they're helping oh i can't i could never
oh my child i could never they could
never
and they they say things like that with
always wisp in their voice
the breathier it is the more dramatic it
is yeah it has to be oh they would be
homeless
the grandchild would be i couldn't turn
my grandchild out on the street
it's like as if she wouldn't get her
butt and gear and get a job and probably
figure this out we'll figure it out
yeah right you know so as if you are the
sole
barrier between your grandchild and
homelessness right homelessness
well and i also know enablers who they
they love to be needed
and they love to play that role of
support and care
and sometimes that's that's they need to
look in the mirror on their own selves
right because if if my daughter does go
get a job she does start
start supporting her kid on her own then
who am i i'm i'm not necessary anymore
i'm not as valuable as i once was and
that's a lie too
when you're participating in funding
someone's insanity you are bringing them
harm that's right
well it's the equivalent of giving a
drunk a drink that's exactly right well
that's tough love no darling that's just
love right love is making grown-ups
grow up so i've got a two young kids
and i i know about this intellectually
what do you
you've got grown-ups grown kids
what do you tell yourself when they if
they were to come back and say hey i
need some support well if they have an
emergency situation
we would help them right but it's not a
pattern love it
the pattern is the problem it's not a
one-off neat kid needs to move back home
that's fine you know a safety net is
okay a hammock
is not okay ah look at that this is the
dave ramsey show